democrats think it's time for nancy
pelosi to be rewarded for her hard work
so much so that they've earmarked 200
million dollars just for her favorite
san francisco park house republicans
tried to block the proposal saying the
money could be better used literally
anywhere else but democrats didn't care
they think it's a great idea to use
taxpayer dollars to upgrade the presidio
park in pelosi's district because she
deserves it
if it weren't for her working 24 7 and
she does it to keep this place going we
wouldn't be going and she does more for
america than any other member i would
submit of this congress times 10. so i
support
the proposal
joining me now to react fox news
contributor tammy bruce tammy welcome to
the show um i have to tell you i shop at
walmart i'm kind of a you know i like to
save my pennies 200
for a park
it's not even a new park it's just to
renovate the park what the heck
yeah look and uh it's funny to listen to
cohen saying oh she deserves it because
of all the work she does yeah and
everybody's been out right everybody's
been doing their zooming they're not
even in there because she's
it's fun it's funny look this is uh like
it's now like monopoly money they have
spent so much money this is like nothing
to them it's like mr moneybags thrown
around the cash the fact of the matter
is we know as we're dealing with this
but the presidio by the way is high-end
real estate it's hotels it's it's a
fancy condos
fancy elite homes uh a golf course right
it's a great place to visit no wonder
she loves it so much i've been there
that's pretty good
yeah this is what this ice cream eating
and martini drinking bubble thinks about
themselves that we work for them
remember that's our money she's spending
and part of what the republicans
suggested was what about money for gold
star families for for veterans uh and
their education uh i would add what
about funding the police what about
instead of putting 200 million into that
elite area what about the rest of san
francisco that has become a dumpster
fire this is an extraordinary statement
about their elitism and about what they
think of us which is nothing uh and and
the fact that they view each other as
you know masters of the universe which
of course uh that's not quite what they
are to say the least
yeah well it also appears to be a
payback because the presidio trust by
the way i don't know any park that i
visit that has its own trust but this
presidio park does the presidio trust
gave nancy pelosi 19 million dollars in
donations over the last year one million
dollars in june
i mean they're using our money what's
your question
that's right so there you've got the
though that of course was just a little
cash in her hand right yeah and this is
about 200 million they talk about a
return on investment
20 million bucks to nancy pelosi you
know 10 times uh is what you'll get back
of our money this is in the normal
business world that would be grift it
would be embezzlement it would be
certainly illegal and this is what we
have to recognize is the nature of what
they get away with so often rachel and
then we wonder why they treat us
why they behave like criminals and they
treat us like we're like little uh
irritant chihuahuas biting at their
ankles yeah they've got to get a wake-up
call next year to say the least all of
this has to change yeah well it's tucked
into a 3.5 trillion dollar bill so i
guess that um you know 200 million seems
like chump change i think for 200
million tammy we all should be able to
go to the park and get some of her fancy
ice cream for free um if we go
yeah ice cream for everyone the biggest
the freezer of ice cream on god's green
earth in every city of the country but
no that won't happen either because
they're mean they are mean tammy you're
not mean i love you thanks for joining
me tonight thank you
thank you ma'am hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else